how did the birds and the bees Taco with
your
son so good yeah nail it I think I
nailed it pretty sure I nailed it did
you have to have like a formal I I had a
I had a a uh I did have a talk I did uh
with him I feel like it was this exact
energy I did um no eye contact was made
I looked down out of the ceiling
floor and then when i' finish the
statement go we good and then I was out
we're cool
homie uh no all but uh his generation is
obviously much different than mine I all
I said was you know obviously uh if you
have any questions box uh under uh the
car we don't use in the garage please
take a look take your
time lock the door your mother won't be
home till late get in and out leave
everything as you found it give youself
about a 15minute cush trust me on that
one
oh god um but I I had to talk to him
about um you know
porn that's the birds and the bees talk
these days it is it's different uh it's
a that's why I say it's a different
generation put on that helmet you go to
the VR yes simulation yes and you ask
the bot for permission that's how the
kids do it these days but you go to the
back of La weekly call the 1 1800 number
I open the door and just let him know
that there nothing was off limits it was
totally safe all that stuff but I did
say you are going to be bombarded with
uh stuff that I was never B if I wanted
private time as I like to call it yeah
um back in the day it was Sports
Illustrated that was that was my private
time yeah okay their private time you
know you've seen the internet I don't
have to describe what's on there it's
horrific as far as the options and the
choices and the things and the so and it
comes out of it comes out of nowhere and
the thing is is he's a good boy but you
know he goes over to friends house who
have older
Brothers you can't control everything
you just can't and so you just try to
educate them that there are things out
there you know and you may see things or
hear things you know I heard you know
things that didn't make any sense and I
I wish I would have had so I always had
to go to my either my sister's boyfriend
or somebody that I could go to and be
like so what does this mean because I
remember seeing in the movie risky
business he's like buffing were two
different things or whatever and I
thought they were the same thing or
remember that movie yeah buffing or
something oh I didn't yeah so I thought
I thought I met bu and I don't know you
know like I just didn't know things
don't ask a girl to you don't know
things when you're young and when
someone says oh you jerked off you're
like yeah what especially when you're
super young you just don't know all the
nomenclature and stuff so I said just
come to me and I will explain everything
I can and if you see or hear something
that shocks you and it confuses you just
come to me and ask just send it to me
I'll save it on my phone I'll watch it
as many times as I need to
I'll do a thorough
review and I'll get back to you maybe
I'll I'll explore all the rest of her
work to make sure she's someone worth
investing know she's credible yeah oh
it's a good source good source material
I do my own research in this house we do
our own research okay that's so
fascinating to me there is a a great
talk um uh by Gail d d NES it's a TED
Talk and it's about how you know boys
look when you're 12 13 you want to see
boobies and you should be able to see
boobies you know the and Dan Mintz yes
stand up he um has this great joke he's
very like dry onliners and he goes you
know gr like things are so different now
with watching porn like when I was you
know a kid I had to wait for the Sears
catalog to come and then I have to flip
to the lingerie section but this day and
age I can just go to
sears.com that's great that's a good one
it's such a good joke that's a good one
you know but it's like every 13 boy
should be able to go see boobies but if
you go Google boobies
crazy stuff comes up that they no one
should ever have to see it escalates
quickly escalates to Google sex or
something and then you think that's what
sex is that's not what sex is and
there's so much confus but let's be
honest if everybody went back and
thought genuinely about your first
sexual encounters whatever it was a make
out session or actual sex or being felt
up or groping or whatever it was it was
all uncomfortable it was all awkward it
was all Uncharted water it was all
confusing yeah we had braces half of us
got tness and then after you did the
groping or the make out or the you know
whatever you would Retreat back to your
friend group and say this is what
happened was that am I am I in the
ballpark here is that is that what's
yeah I made out you stick your tongue in
the mouth yeah you know and then okay
good you know don't stick too far like
yeah course but you have to well now I
think you have to consent on an app
first I mean there's a lot of but it's
about that bad but but that's how it
worked you had to it was a it was an
awkward thing that you had to discover
as you went and you just hoped that you
were in a friend group or a peer group
that had the kind of the same values the
kind of the same you know respectability
you know that you were like he's a good
guy or she's a good person or whatever
and so that's you gravitated towards
each other and you were kind to one
another and you tried to do it the right
way yeah you know but that's the best
you could hope for yeah and it's I think
it's still true but I don't know because
it's hilarious I watched my my daughter
go through high school and I they don't
date they I I used to have a girlfriend
like in my freshman year all the way
through my you're like we had and we go
date night I know but now nobody dates
nobody cares there's no boyfriend
girlfriend thing and I'm like well was I
know I was crazy horny in high school
are any you know I don't want to ask but
are they not they're not it's their uh
the age that um kids are losing their
virginity is going up it's getting very
very high the age that people are having
girlfriend boy they kind of like text
constantly they'll just like constantly
text with each other and Snapchat with
each other and instead of getting
together they're not down for the
private time I think that if you're a
boy who can do the private time whenever
with your computer or your phone you
know and it's a sure thing beautiful
women yeah yeah it's or just many
different
scenarios and then it's sort of like oh
I'm now I've seen this so I don't know
how to do that so now I'm insecure I
think you're am I expected to do that
yeah you know and I think that that that
boys probably see it more as like
research like I want to learn how to do
this thing and then it it's probably
even more I mean imagine like in our day
like it was just like awkward and clumsy
imagine right now a guy grabbing your
hair you be like what are you doing like
where did that come from you know I
think there's a lot of that just like
confusion if you've been watching porn
first I would agree